A Kung Fu Master...
Is Prepared to Train Hard...
Move Fast...
Be Brave...
And Above All...
be ready, for anything.
Perfect.
Really?
No. Again!
But next January, nothing can prepare him...
for his greatest challenge yet...
Who are you? I'm Li Shan, I'm looking for
my son...
gasps.
You lost your son? Yes, many years ago.
I lost my father...I'm very sorry.
Thank You
long pause
Well, good luck to you. You too, I hope you
find your son. And I hope you find your father...
/facepalm
Hey Youtubers it's Charlie, so the first trailer
for kung fu panda three just dropped, so this
is going to be a breakdown of that footage.
There's one very notable addition of the cast
whose voice you may have recognized. Most you
guys probably forgot that there was going
to be a kung fu panda three. Kung fu panda
two happened back in 2011, so it's going to
be like five years between these movies. They
had like a big post credits teaser where you
see all these pandas, like, it's all about
the mystery of Jack Black's family. That is
what Hollywood calls "development hell". That
is actually pretty normal for really big animated
films like this to take just giant armies
of people, so it's not like making a live-action
film, you can just like turn one over every
two years. The biggest thing is that Bryan
Cranston is playing Po's father, Jack Black's
father. As you can see from the trailer, you know,
pandas, not the brightest bulb in the box. They are
turning, like, all those funny quirks in Po
into hereditary things, as in, like, all pandas
act like Po, or as at least Po's father. The villain
is being played by JK Simmons, so picture
J Jonah Jameson yelling at Po. There was a
foreign-language trailer that leaked early
to YouTube that they've since removed it, that
they posted him. He's basically like a giant bull
his name is Kai. The quote from JK Simmons
just says "let's just say Kai's been away. Now that
he's back, he's not happy about life in general"
one thing he finds when he returns is that
pandas make him particularly unhappy, so his
arc in the film is going to be trying to get
rid of that lost colony of pandas. It's been
a while since the first movie but the whole
conceit is that Po thinks that he's the last
of this kind, he thinks he is the last panda. Supposedly
he's looking for revenge, but we don't know
what event he's attributing to the pandas.
But he did reference his character in whiplash
you know, like, the really angry teacher with
Miles Teller. He said that, like, all the rage
that Miles Teller gives them in whiplash he
is now attributing to Jack Black, so like, when
whenever he wants to get worked up he just
thinks of Jack Black. I'm actually pretty excited
to see what's going on with Bryan Cranston's
character he has played good characters like
he was a good character in Godzilla everybody
was here Bryan Cranston and they think Walter
White see wonder if there is like some added
layer to his character where he is not quite
good not quite bad but I'm not expecting any
secret kung fu skills like Po that other international
trailer that was taken down can be a lot more
about the kung fu that goes on in the film
if you member from kung fu panda two it was
all about him playing with that drop of water
and then he did the same thing with the cannibals
the end of the film this gets even more trippy
is if you like spending time and space so
expect an even bigger version of the sequence
like that cannonball sequence from the second
film this really only a couple things you
can do a sequels you can travel inward you
can deal with like the character's emotional
journey even more or he can deliver an even
bigger spectacle meet it's been four years
that they would leave you hanging with something
like really bad ass to walk away with the
other really big addition to the cast is Rebel
Wilson as Mei Mei she doesn't appear in the
trailer but she plays another panda with like
really bad ass kung fu skills the only quote
the Rebel Wilson is given is that she is super
into ribbon dancing and she's a funny creative
panda is you probably going to wind up being
a love interest for Jack Black's character
Musa panda who learn kung fu he didn't take
about celibacy or anything like that but I'm
actually of the offender rubble Wilson so
should be fun the movie itself is going to
be released January 29 next year in 2016 which
seems like a like a weird release date but
I guess they just didn't want to bump up against
Star Wars the force awakens if you ever wanted
to guarantee that people would not go see
your movie just release it on the same day
of the new Star Wars movie so moving this
to January pry pretty smart move DreamWorks
animation is a studio hasn't been doing so
hot financially so there like they're doubling
down on the really big stuff so don't be surprised
when you see a whole lot more how to train
your Dragon sequels kung fu panda sequels
like stuff based on their most popular franchises
I was a big fan of the the first two kung
fu panda film so this looks like it'll be
a lot of fun for those you asking about inside
out yes I will be doing and inside out review
this weekend so be sure to subscribe to get
that just just like my Jurassic Park view
what I'll do is all of the like a non-spoilery
part of the video first and then the second
half of the video augmented spoilers in case
you haven't seen it yesterday I did of big
trailer video for all my favorite games from
E3 you can click here to watch that and you
can click here to learn what game growth season
six thank you so much for watching, everybody
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!